l'écu est mort vive l'euro les quinze
réunis en sommet à madrid ont en effet
décidé de baptiser euros la future
monnaie unique européenne qui devrait
entrer en circulation le 1er janvier
2002 prochaine étape cruciale de l'union
monétaire la sélection des pays qui
auront le privilège de monter dans le
premier train de la monnaie unique en
principe le 1er janvier 99 à madrid pour
france 2 philippe sassier c'est une
journée historique
historique parce que en 2002 vous
pourrez chiffonné jeter cheville et il
aurait été remplacé par leur haut
historique parce que à madrid on a
choisi le nom de la monnaie unique est
définitivement le scénario de passage à
cette monnaie le 1er janvier 1999
l'épi admis au club de la monnaie unique
gèleront les parités de leur monnaie les
citoyens n'utiliseront pas cette monnaie
pour payer leur baguette de pain leur
loyer ou leurs impôts avant 2002 les dès
1999 les états s'en serviront notamment
pour émettre leurs emprunts une décision
importante pour affirmer la confiance
dans la monnaie nouvelle a madrid c'est
la confiance dans l'europe et le marché
unique qui a été rappelé
c'est le facteur de stabilité dont nous
avons peu ce groupe donc l'europe marché
unique cesse de redouter le désordre
monétaire en son sens
l'europe a donc bien descendu l'escalier
de madrid né qui fera partie du club
monnaie unique les membres seront
choisis selon les fameux critères de
maastricht tu es disciples jetair
notamment examen de passage au début de
1998 on est enfin sorti des ambiguïtés
reste une incertitude la situation
économique en europe dont la
détérioration pourrait rendre plus
difficile la marche vers la monnaie
unique